ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU JUNE CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA NGUYEN
O'DONNELL. ASCEND PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK CORK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEAM
RELATIVE AREAS VIA FOOD WA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
RIGHT
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE'RE. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YES YEAR KHAN. IMAM IS THERE.
AND THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. I'M
NOT A GUN. ALLOW US ALL TO
REMAIN GROUNDED WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING. NEVER CONSTANTLY
BEING TESTED BY YOU. TRUE
HAPPINESS AND SORROW TO SEE IF
WE REMEMBER YOU. FONG MIGHTY
GOD ALLOW US TO REMAIN IN
GRATITUDE. SO THAT WE CAN SERVE
OUR LOCAL. DISTRICTS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I MEAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MRS HERE
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE GUESS AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. AND
DINNER ON THE WAY TO EXPAND
COLLABORATION. THE PROPOSAL
WILL PROTECT US FROM THANK YOU
YOU MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY
SIX. AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES.
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA.
MITHRAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
RUBIO SHOOTING AND DOLLY TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
SB FORTY EIGHT LIMóN FROM TE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS%
COMMITTEE TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. SB SIX FORTY SIX
HERTZBERG FROM THE TIP FROM THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
TO THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
OKAY. AB I'M SORRY SB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT BAKER FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
AND NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. TO WITHDRAW SB FIVE
FORTY EIGHT EGGMAN FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILE THIS BILL IS NOT
FISCAL WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
LIVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE FILE ITEMS
ONE THROUGH FIFTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY
SIX OF THE MEMBERS TO TWENTY
SEVEN WITH THE MEMBERS FIVE
HUNDRED NUMBER TWO FORTY ONE
WITH A MEMBERS 391-432-5917 SIX
TWO EIGHT OH SEVEN. WITH A
MINISTER SEVENTY WITH A MEMBER
SIXTY SEVEN THREE TWENTY THREE
WITH A MINISTRY NINETY TWO WITH
A MEMBERS THREE THIRTY TO THE
MEDICINE CYNICAL SIX SIXTY
MINUTES. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS.
SIXTEEN AND EIGHTEEN WILL PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN. WILL PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEMS NINETEEN THROUGH
TWENTY THREE. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR ACR NINETY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. FROM THE
CURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY ONE
BY SIMPLY RIVER TRUE RELATIVE
TO HELP HOMES AWARENESS MONTH.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF ACR NINETY ONE TO DECLARE
THIS MONTH. AS HEALTHY HOMES
MONTH. WE ALL KNOW THAT HEALTHY
HOMES ARE CRUCIAL TO THE
SUCCESS AND HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT SO MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND RESIDENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE UNAWARE
OF THE POTENTIAL HEALTH RISKS
IN THEIR HOME. SUCH AS LEAD
MOLD AND CARBON MONOXIDE. MANY
OF THESE RISKS ARE NOT OBVIOUS
TO THE AVERAGE HOMEOWNER AND
CAN CAUSE SERIOUS IF NOT DEADLY
HARM TO RESIDENTS IF LEFT
UNTREATED. WHILE THIS IS
SPENDING NATIONAL PROBLEM
CALIFORNIA FACES CONSIDERABLE
HEALTHY HOME CHALLENGES. WE
HAVE ALMOST A HALF A MILLION
HOMES WITH MOLD ONE POINT TWO
CALIFORNIA HOMES. HAVE SIGNS OF
MICE OVER ONE POINT SIX MILLION
REPORT COCKROACHES OVER TWO
MILLION REPORT WATER LEAKS.
ACCORDING TO RECENT AMERICAN
HOUSING SURVEY REPORT NEARLY
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
HOMES HAVE SEVERELY INADEQUATE.
OR MODERATELY INADEQUATE
PLUMBING HEATING AND ELECTRICAL
SYSTEMS. ACR NINETY ONE.
FOLLOWS IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF THE
FEDERAL HOUSING URBAN
DEPARTMENT WHICH DECLARES JUNE
AS NATIONAL HEALTHY HOMES MONTH
EACH YEAR- I ASK YOU TO JOIN IN
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE. OF
HEALTHY HOMES IN CALIFORNIA AND
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MR
CHIU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLES
WE HAVE BEEN FOR QATAR'S CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A. HOW LONG
MEMBERS THIRTY THERE BUT THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION MEMBERS. THIRTY
YEARS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE THERE
FIFTY NINE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEMS.
TWENTY FIVE THREE THIRTY
SIX. MEMBERS WILL MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN CLERK WILL READ. SO WE
WILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SOME OF OUR QUE HAN AND OTHERS
IN EQUITY THE GOVERNMENT SAMOA
THEIR POWER CAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
AND MAINTENANCE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE SIMPLY ADD TECHNICAL
AMENDS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE CARPOOL OPEN
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THE- DESIRE
TO DO. ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE. YOU CAN. CALL
THE ROLL TELEVOTES EYES FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THINKING-
CONCURRENCE IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERTAIN CURTAIN. WOMEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY
NINE BY SOME MEMBER OF OUR K.
HAND AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE
TWO CERTIFICATES OF DEATH.
SERVER BARTENDER RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBER IS AB FOUR THIRTY NINE
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE ON MONDAY WE
CELEBRATED LGBTQ PRIDE DAY. AND
TODAY WE GET TO FURTHER OUR
KNOWLEDGE THE TRANS INDIVIDUALS
WHO LIVE IN EACH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES BY SENDING THIS
BILL. TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
SIMPLY OUT OF CO AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MAKING HIS MARK IN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE LOCAL
OVER THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL DISCLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY THREE
NINE ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS. OKAY. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THIS DAY ALLEN
FILE ITEMS NINE AND FORTY ONE
THEIR RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE
WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR POSSIBLE
SOLUTION FIFTY FOUR BY
CELEBRATORY ANOTHER FILTER TO
THE SEVENTY FIFTH SEVENTY FIRST
ANNIVERSARY OF THE KOREAN WAR
SINKER RESOLUTION THIRTY BY
SENATE DALY RELATIVE TO CENTER
WEDNESDAY. THE CLERK WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE TO ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THESE RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS
VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE
ROLE IS OPEN I DIDN'T HEAR THE
CHIME. HA MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THEIR THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTIONS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS
THIRTY NINE THROUGH FORTY FIVE.
IS ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING ON
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
A CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE WAS
SOLUTION FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO THE SEVENTY FIRST
ANNIVERSARY OF THE KOREAN WAR.
WELL OPEN THE WRONG CONTENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THERE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I. SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SOME OF WHOM
RESOLUTION EIGHTY EIGHT I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIXTY EIGHT
ZERO SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT. SENATE BILL
SEVEN AWAY I SIXTY EIGHT ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT IS
THERE A CHANCE IMMIGRANT
RESOLUTION. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. MEMBERS I ASKED
YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. OFF THE FLOOR.
YEAH.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR OR
TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE MOVING
TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON IN A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THIS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
TODAY I ASK YOU DURING THE
MEMORY OF THE RESIDENT FROM
OUTSIDE OF MY DISTRICT BUT ONE
WHOSE IMPACT CAN BE FELT DEEPLY
BY MANY MEMBERS AND STAFF HERE
TODAY. RAISED IN RIALTO AND A
LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO. MARJORIE WILL
FORGIVE PAST WEEK JUNE JUNE
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
SURROUNDED BY HER LOVED ONES. A
TEACHER OF OVER THIRTY YEARS A
WIFE TO KEVIN WILL FORK FOR
OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND A
WONDERFUL MOTHER TO BOTH TAYLOR
WILL FORK. OF MY LEGISLATIVE
TEAM AND JOE WILL FORK OF THE
ASSEMBLY DEFEAT- TEAM.
MARJORIE'S LEGACY INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITOL BUILDING
DEMONSTRATES HER UNYIELDING BUT
BUT NEVER LANDS TO THOSE
SURROUNDING HER. MARJORY
OBTAINED HER BACHELOR OF ARTS
DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. AND
SPENT MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS AS
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER IN
THE L. GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND IN THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF HER CAREER
TEACHING AT DAVIS DAVID REES
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. MY HEART NOT
ONLY ACHES FROM SHARING A
PASSION FOR EDUCATION OF THE
TEACHER WITH MARJORIE BUT ALSO
SHARING THE GRIEF OF A FAMILY
THAT HAS BECOME A PART OF MY
FAMILY. AND THAT I CARE SO
DEEPLY FOR. MARJORIE LIVED A
FULL RICH AND DIVERSE LIFE
WHICH IS REFLECTED IN HER
KINDNESS AND GENUINE CARE SO
OFTEN ON DISPLAY WHEN IN HER
PRESENCE. I ASK IN HONOR OF
MARJORIE BUT YOU ALL DO WHAT
SHE WOULD WANT YOU TO BE KIND
ACCEPTING AND CARING TO ONE
ANOTHER. WHICH IS HER GREATEST
GIFT. IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE
KNOWN MARJORIE A PRIVILEGE TO
HAVE HER SON IS PART OF MY
LEGISLATIVE TEAM HERE AT THE
CAPITOL ANY PRIVILEGE TO HONOR
HER TODAY. ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
MARJORIE WILL FORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO. MISTER
ALI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO INJURE
IN THE MEMORY OF A DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANT OF THE NORTH
STATE SUSANVILLE POLICE OFFICER
RYAN RYAN BARHAM IN ITS
EXTENSIVE TENURE OF SERVICE HE
ALSO WORKED WITH Y. RICA POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SERVED AS A LASSEN
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFF AND
WORKED AS A FIELD TRAINING
OFFICER IN A RANGE MASTER.
OFFICER BARHAM WAS AMOUNT
SHASTA NATIVE GRADUATED FROM A
CLOUD HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX SIX HE WAS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL RODEO ASSOCIATION
QUALIFYING TWICE FOR STATE
FINALS. THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE
REMAINED ACTIVE IN RANCHING AND
FARMING COMMUNITY I WAS
FAMILIAR FACE AT LOCAL ARENAS.
HE WAS AN AVID HUNTER AND
ANGLER AND ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SHARED HIS KNOWLEDGE OF. OF
TECHNIQUES AND PRODUCTS THAT
WOULD IMPROVE OTHERS HUNTING
AND ANGLING EXPERIENCE. OFFICER
BERM GRADUATED FROM THE COLLEGE
OF THE REDWOODS POLICE ACADEMY
AND WAS SWORN IN AS A LASSEN
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFF IN MAY OF
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE. AFTER
SERVING AS A DEPUTY SHERIFF AND
POLICE OFFICER IN DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS. RYAN RETURNED.
TO THE AREA HELD SUCH DEEP
FAMILY ROOTS RETURN TO LASSEN
COUNTY AS AN OFFICER FOR THE-
SUSANVILLE POLICE DEPARTMENT IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY NINETEEN. HIS
ABOUT SERVICE TO HIS COMMUNITY
IS GREATLY VALUED BY THOSE HE
LEAVES BEHIND. AND HE WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED TODAY WE HONOR
HIS SERVICE BRAVERY AND
DEVOTION. AND SURE DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES WITH HIS FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES. MEMBERS I ASK THAT
YOU JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN THE
MEMORY OF SUSANVILLE POLICE
OFFICER I AM BARHAM. THANK YOU
MISTER ALI MR CHIU YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO HONOR A BELOVED MEMBER
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY.
TONY RODRIGUEZ WHO WE LOST TOO
SOON AFTER HIS RECENT
RETIREMENT. JOSE ANTONY
RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR KNOWN TO ALL
OF US AS TONY. WAS A FATHER
HUSBAND FRIEND LABOUR LEADER
AND DEDICATED MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. HE SPENT HIS ENTIRE
LIFE AND SAN FRANCISCO FROM HIS
CHILDHOOD IN THE EXCELSIOR TO
RAISING HIS FAMILY UNSETTLING
AND BOTTLE HEIGHTS. HIS TO
IMMIGRANT PARENTS HIS FATHER
FROM PORT TO RICCO HIS MOTHER
FROM MEXICO INSPIRED HIM TO
JOIN A UNION AS A WAY OF
SUPPORTING HIS FAMILY AT HOME.
AND CREATING ONE AT WORK. HE
WORKED AS A FIRE SPRINKLER
FITTER. FOR LOCAL FORTY THREE
FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
WHERE HE SERVED ON THE UNION'S
EXECUTIVE BOARD. AS A LONG TIME
ELECTED OFFICER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
AND AS A DELEGATE TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO LABOR COUNCIL. TONY
ALSO SERVED ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIRE COMMISSION. AS
AN ELECTED SAN FRANCISCO
DELEGATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. AND AS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE SAINT
VINCENT DEPAUL SOCIETY AND ST
KEVIN'S PARISH. AS HE WOULD SAY.
I'VE OFTEN BELIEVE THAT TO
AFFECT POSITIVE PROGRESS YOU
HAVE TO BE INVOLVED FOR MORE
THAN. FOR THOSE OF US WHO KNEW
HIM. HIPPOPOTAMUSES WORDS BEING
INVOLVED IN HIS UNION AND HIS
COMMUNITY WAS NOT JUST HIS JOB.
BUT HIS PASSION REFLECTED HIS
VALUES OF FIGHTING FOR WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE. TONY LET HIS LIFE
THROUGH SERVICE LEADERSHIP AND
TRUE AND RARE KINDNESS. HIS
COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY AND TO
THE LIVES OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WILL
LIVE ON FOR MANY YEARS TO COME.
ON BEHALF OF OUR ASSEMBLY I
WANT TO EXTEND OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS LOVING
PARTNER OF OVER FOUR DECADES.
HIS FOUR CHILDREN HIS SIBLINGS
HIS TWENTY NINE NIECES AND
NEPHEWS AND IS BROADER SAN
FRANCISCO FAMILY. BROTHER TONY.
REST IN POWER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISTER KING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE SITTER
MEMORIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MALES BECOMES GOING TO ADD TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SEPARATE JUST
BECAUSE A JOURNAL MEMORY FOR
TWENTY RODRIGUEZ- I THINK HE
SUMMARIZED HIS INCREDIBLE LIFE
IS INCREDIBLE SERVICE TO OUR
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO BUT ALSO
TO THE- WORKING PEOPLE A GROUP
OF FOLKS WHO ARE FINDING IT
HARDER AND HARDER TO LIVE IN
OUR CITY AND FRANKLY IN OUR
STATE- TONY WAS A PROGRESS AT
THE SAN FRANCISCO HE GRADUATE
FROM PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL AND
ALSO ATTENDED. CITY COLLEGE
BEFORE HE SET OUT TO BE IN HIS
SPRINKLER FITTERS UNION ALSO BE
A VERY ACTIVE MEMBER OF OUR SAN
FRANCISCO FABRIC- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO MENTIONED
HIS SERVICE UNDER FIRE
COMMISSION HE RECENTLY EVEN
DURING THIS PANDEMIC JUST GOT
ELECTED AS A DAM ALEXION- WHICH
UNLIKE UNLIKE OTHER PLACES IS
ACTUALLY A FAIRLY- FIERY KIND
OF RACE IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
EVEN DURING AND EVEN WHEN WE
WERE FACING HEALTH CHALLENGES-
TONY WAS ALWAYS THERE- FOR THE
FIGHT ALWAYS THERE TO BE ACTIVE
AND ALWAYS THERE TO BE THERE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY- I JUST
WANTED TO STAND UP TO DATE
AGAIN- WILL HOLD ON WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- FROM SAN FRANCISCO
ASK OUR ASSEMBLY TO ADJOURN AND
TONI. RODRIGUEZ IS HONOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER TO MEMBER
PLEASE BRING NAMES THAT SB
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL. I REQUEST
YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL.
DISTRESS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MISSION.
MADAM SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY EIGHT TO
REMOVE ITEM. EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO BLOWN FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE AND ORDER THE
FILE ORDER THE BILL TO THIRD
READING WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. INTERNAT
MEANT MEMBERS I'M ORDERING IT
SB HOLD OPEN TO PROCESS BUDGET
RELATED BILLS AND OTHER MATTERS
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY
FIFTH NO FLOOR SESSION AND NO
CHECK IN SESSION. MONDAY JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION ONE
PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN THIS RACE
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTH. AT ONE PM.